do you think there's a there's
is there precedent for this
when you look back in history yeah
do you think or as a scientist and you
look at
i don't know leaps of understanding or
has there been anything like this before
a great deceit or a great concept or a
great
has anything been done like this before
or has it simply not been possible
before
i want to answer that with
i think it's a yes and no okay i think
there are a thousand precedents every
piece of this has happened somewhere
with with the exception of something
highly technical
but the sum total of what has happened
here i'm pretty sure is is novel
and
you know i said at the beginning of
covid i don't know if i set it into a
camera but i think i did
this is the biggest thing that's ever
happened and i meant that and i was you
know i wasn't forgetting about world
wars or anything like it but there was
something about this that it really
truly was global right it's even a world
war there are places it doesn't touch
right
this
was
a uniting a potentially galvanizing
moment across the entire globe and of
course something interrupted that
galvanizing process
but
the way in which whatever has happened
on the far side of that has put us
together has created a global
conversation
it has burned out
many of the tools that
whatever that antagonistic force is
their best tools are evaporating on them
right they have called attention there
are too many people aware of the tricks
and
you know some people will hover at the
edge and maybe they'll go back to
imagining the world is normal but a lot
of people won't so
i think the answer is no i think this is
the net the net outgrowth here is
unprecedented
it's interesting to me that
what made a lot of it possible to
if this was if you know if there was a
cabal that decided to this is the time
to press the button it was the internet
that made it possible
you know for example the whole working
from home
you know everyone being able to retreat
to their to their hutches and and be
isolated one from another
ordering food ordering everything that
you wanted you know
for a lot of people it was possible for
the first time
and i ironically or paradoxically
the seeds of the undoing are in
the tool that made it possible because
the internet also made it possible for
all of us
to reach out to each other
they were able to bring the internet to
bear
as a as part of how they were able to
get us all organized in the way that
they wanted us organised but the
internet is also has also freed us
it's it's so something it's been there's
a bug in the system that they weren't
aware of and it's that i'm doing they
thought they could do they thought the
internet is here we can do it now let's
go
but within the internet has been the
seeds of their undoing i think that is
the it's the way in which we've been
able to mine information share
information
circulate it around the globe get it
into each other's hands
and that'll be their undoing
so i'll
try to do it quickly but
i have a model for this
there is a ratio of
conspiracy
that goes into whatever has happened and
then there's emergent
phenomena that aren't conspiratorial
they're not conscious
we don't know what the admixture is
right but it's some frag you know is
there conspiracy involved here well you
know yeah you've got big pharma and
fiduciary responsibility which is
another way of saying that there's a
conspiracy of people trying to do
something in their interests which are
which consider our interests unimportant
so yeah there's some conspiracy
but here's the thing
the emergent part
is effectively we can
uh
we can call that it's it's an involved
product it's a it's an adaptive product
of evolution in the very real sense
now here's the here's the important part
to the extent that part of what we are
up against is an emergent property and
not a conscious group of people who
think about how to outfox us
that thing will have a couple of
characteristics one it will be
ferociously powerful
right
but it will be stupid about anything it
hasn't seen before right the fact of it
being a product of evolution tells you
it will be good inside the zone that it
that built it and it will be a [ __ ]
when it runs up against things that it
hasn't encountered
now that is what you're talking about so
i keep on thinking about uh sheldon
cooper character and big bang theory the
big brain you know he's this
the the pr the premise is it's the four
cleverest guys in california all should
have all lived together
and they have a they have a they have
their understanding of the world and
sheldon cooper is a kind of autistic
savant
and he's incredibly smart
he's a genius level individual
but he's continually outsmarted and
undone by the woman who lives across the
hall from them
she's just a regular joe regular jane
but she's got human empathies
and street smarts and other
characteristics that he simply cannot
ever allow for because he's never felt
them
under his undoing every time so this
it's like the world's been taken over by
by by someone who lacks
something crucial
there's a crucial absence and that is
what's going to bring them down they're
not allowing for
humanity
humanity is an extraordinary
event we've been here for 200 300 000
years as homo sapiens and we've been
here for millions of years as
as variations on the same theme
and
it's not by accident that we've lasted
this long
and we've got all sorts of innate
characteristics the the human animal
isn't it everyone's excited about
artificial intelligence and all the rest
of it but the flesh and blood and bone
human animal
is
the most extraordinary thing that the
universe has ever seen
and
you can't outwit it
and
something that lacks
that empathic connection to humanity
is trying to run humanity
and it doesn't
fundamentally understand the animal that
it's trying to control
and that's why the animal will get away
from it
we will get away from them because they
don't understand us and they don't
really appreciate what we're capable of
[Music]